i don't know what you can say but what
can you say because i know you did
something with nelly
it's fire to me it's like the type of
song that people will be like i didn't
know i needed this
and now i do you know it's one of those
and to me nelly is like one of my ogs
he's one of the first
artists one of the first black artists
that blended hip hop and country in a
really
unique and profound way
he's a visionary he's super ahead of his
time with all of that and being able to
create with him
in any capacity is an honor for me what
did you do with the brothers osborne
i love them so much honestly i think
that they are helping
to make country music more inclusive and
more diverse and we've had some real
conversations
about what that looks like and what that
means and why it's important for us to
stay connected
and we made some great music too and
while we wait for those collaborations
to drop breeland just re-released his
single cross country with grammy nominee
mickey guyton
as another sort of young black country
artist
are you feeling that sky is the limit at
this point or do you feel that that
walls still need to come down
in order for you to sort of fulfill your
dreams i think
both honestly i know that's a weird
answer but i think
that there are still some barriers that
need to be broken there are a lot of
people who feel right now that they
can't
make country music that they can't
listen to country music that they can't
listen to country radio they can't go to
a country concert
and all i'm trying to do is break
deconstruct that a little bit
and say hey actually it's more inclusive
than you think we just have to work for
it